NICK BUTCHER: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: Wonderful.
NICK BUTCHER: Let's do it.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
we're rolling, awesome.
So hi, welcome back to Devoxx.
This is Devoxx 2013,
and I'm here with Nick
to talk about Android--
NICK BUTCHER: Hi
MALE SPEAKER: -from
a design perspective.
Is that the right word, design?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
absolutely, like what
it is to be an Android app,
how you design an Android
app to kind of look,
as well as work
like you expect an
Android app to be.
MALE SPEAKER: So UX
is the word part,
and then the rest
is taste and color.
Are you saying there's one
way to build apps only?
NICK BUTCHER: No.
I'd say there's many ways
you can build an app.
But I'd say there's
certain things you
can do to make your app work
like an Android app is expected
to work so that your users
will know how to use it
and they'll know how to navigate
around the content within it.
The look and feel, the
aesthetic qualities
like colors, certain
interaction patterns-- those
can be customized to
bring your own personality
to your application.
So if you look at a variety
of applications out there,
look at something
like the Expedia app
to the Google Play
Music application--
MALE SPEAKER: They're
quite different.
NICK BUTCHER: --to the
alarm clock application.
They look very, very different.
They all have their
own feel to them,
but they follow certain rules,
as in interaction patterns
and touch target and
presentation themes,
which means that when
a user picks it up,
they'll know how to use it.
MALE SPEAKER: Right, so
that's absolutely the key.
So, I'm an Android developer.
Should I also be the designer?
Does that even make sense?
NICK BUTCHER: If you want to
do both, if you can do both,
then awesome.
More power to you.
I enjoy doing both.
It depends really.
If you are working
on a big project
and you can have a
dedicated design resource,
that's awesome.
And I think a lot of the
most polished applications
are like that.
If you're a one man band
who is just a developer
interested in design,
then hopefully there's
a lot of resources
we're putting out there
that you can get up to speed, so
things like the Android Design
guidelines, which have been
around for about a year now
and have progressively
gotten more and more--
MALE SPEAKER: So you're
actually upgrading those
with the releases of Android.
NICK BUTCHER: Right,
right, with each release
and as each new pattern,
so every now and then,
such as when the Navigation
Drawer gained popularity,
we started documenting
it and saying
we think this is the best
way you can use this pattern,
added that to the design site.
As well as the show that
I do once a month or so,
called "Android
Design in Action,"
which is all about how
to design for Android.
So hopefully we're
putting the resources out
there that if you're a developer
who's interested in design
that you can get up to speed.
MALE SPEAKER: So, how
hard is it to start?
I mean there's the
Android Design guidelines.
Do you need to read all of
it and implement all of it,
or you have it all
wrong, or is there a way,
like you don't have too
high of a bar to start with?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
My favorite thing about the
Android Design guidelines
is how short they are.
It's not a massive tome of human
interface guidelines written
in very dry language that
is hard to get through.
You can actually read the entire
site in about half an hour,
45 minutes.
It's not a huge
amount of content,
so I would recommend,
yeah, read it.
This is the basis of what
it is to be an Android
application, how
you should operate.
So I'd say it's a great
start to read that and then
go from there.
There's a flourishing community
of people out there talking
about Android Design,
particularly on Google+,
which is where I see most
of the chatter happening,
as well as other places, like
Dribbble and other places.
I think Android Design
conversation is really
picking up.
MALE SPEAKER: So
what kind of reward
can a developer expect
from actually having
followed those guidelines, spent
the time actually designing
this, maybe on the
Play Store with users
and interacting with them.
Does that actually
make a difference?
Can you actually
see changes in apps
that have gone from
default design to something
where there's more--
NICK BUTCHER:
Absolutely, thoroughly,
like one case study
that comes to mind
is Pocket, the read
it later application.
They did an exercise where
users were misunderstanding
their archive feature.
And they changed
the user interface
to follow our up
paradigm, where you
have the button in the top left
to take you up within the app.
And they changed
archive to an action
on the right, which is where
users are expecting it.
And they saw some crazy
increase like 700% more use
of the feature or more
understanding of the feature.
So there is definitely a lot of
benefit to an individual app.
I think the overall goal of
following the Android Design is
hopefully a better application.
So the process of going through
and thinking about your design
and improving it and
standing on the shoulders
of all the hard work gone into
the Android Design patterns.
It should make your
application better.
So we do see a lot of
comments and feedback
from users, like the apps
which are nicely designed
tend to have a higher rating.
As well as on the
Google Play Store,
there's obviously things
like the Top Lists,
as well as things
like Editors' Choice,
or even there's a collection
of applications called
the Beautiful Design application
list, or collection I guess.
So you can't get into those
kind of things without having--
MALE SPEAKER: And they
should be good inspiration.
If you look at those,
if they got there,
probably if you do
something similar you can--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, if you're
looking for inspiration,
go to the Beautiful
Design collection.
Just Google for Android
Google Play Beautiful
Design and you'll
get this collection.
And these are some
of the applications
that Google Play recognizes
as some of the best in class.
MALE SPEAKER: So
we've just released
the Android 4.4, KitKat.
Does that change anything
to the Design guidelines?
NICK BUTCHER: KitKat
to me is a maturing
of the Design guidelines.
MALE SPEAKER: But that means
a small change, still, right?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, exactly.
I don't think we've
radically changed direction,
but we've refined
all over the place.
It's all about polishing.
It's all about delivering
a better experience.
So color, like we
touched on earlier on,
we've backed away from having
these kind of very, very
strong accent colors.
So by default the
user interface used
to use a lot of this blue
that was kind of like, jolt
of contrast in your application.
And it didn't particularly
leave a lot of room
for your app to have
its own personality,
because if your color-- your
branding was red, for example,
you have all these blue
stock controls in there,
it could be quite
clashing, really.
So what we've tried to do
with the OS is back that away.
So by default you'll get
more of a neutral experience.
But the reason is to leave
room for apps to innovate,
so an app can then express
its own personality.
It can then customize
on top of that.
So things like that,
I think is showing
a maturing of the platform.
So the platform is
kind of getting out
the way to let the
apps really shine.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
And then would you recommend
people actually changing
anything at this point
for KitKat specifically?
Or is it just more
choice and more way
to express themselves if needed?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
There are some other
features as well,
which I'm quite excited about.
So one thing I'm really
excited about for designers
is the new Immersive Modes.
So you now get access
to the entire screen.
So if you have these
on-screen buttons
you can now draw behind them
or hide them temporarily
or persistently.
So that unleashes a whole
new kind of interaction mode.
So I think if you look
at Google Play Books,
for example, which does a
beautiful job of hiding all
the system chrome and
getting out of the way
and really focusing on
the experience of reading,
and then coming back
and making it really,
really easy to navigate
again when you need to,
I think those are the kind
of opportunities that KitKat
provides for designers
and developers
to have a really rich interface,
MALE SPEAKER: OK, cool.
So, before we close, I have
an app on the Play Store.
It's doing OK.
I have a 3.x something
rating, which is not bad,
but I want to improve that.
Design guidelines is where I go.
Is there this one trick?
Give me that one flip to
switch to get a better design.
NICK BUTCHER: OK, so,
I would say the one
thing you can really do is focus
on your information hierarchy.
I think the one
thing that people--
I know kind of coming from
a development background--
I'm really excited
to dive into the app
and create it and use the
latest buttons and libraries
and so on.
But I think the biggest benefit
you can get in designing
is to really think about
the information hierarchy
and use that to
create your navigation
so that it makes the app
easier to navigate around.
I think the visual stuff
can add a lot on top,
but if the fundamental
information hierarchy
isn't there, then you need
to start from the beginning.
So I'd say yeah, look at
your information hierarchy,
then look on navigation
and interaction patterns
and use that.
And then once you're
kind of there,
then apply the visual stuff.
And one top tip, one thing that
really bugs me of applications
is touch feedback.
Just make sure you do
that properly as well.
It's the simplest thing, but if
an application doesn't respond
when I touch it, then it
feels slow, it feels laggy,
it feels buggy.
So that's my one top tip for
something you should be doing.
Second top tip--
two top tips-- is
use Google Play's beta
functionality as well.
If you are playing
with this stuff,
it's a great, great opportunity
to use the beta testing
functionality.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you want
me to remind what that is?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
exactly, so you
can create a community or a
Google Groups mailing list
and have people
opt in to say, hey,
I've got a high
aptitude for risk.
I'd like to play with the latest
shiniest features before people
and give you more feedback
without the expectation of it
being a stable
production release.
So if you're doing these
kind of refinements,
you can push them to a
smaller slightly less
risk averse kind of group
and get feedback from them
quite quickly without having to
distribute to all your hundreds
and thousands and
millions of users.
MALE SPEAKER: Great,
awesome, thanks for the tips.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
MALE SPEAKER: And the
Android Design guidelines
on the Android--
NICK BUTCHER: Thanks,
It was a pleasure.
Yeah, check out the
Android Design guidelines
at developer.android.com/design,
and follow "Android Design
in Action"
androiddesigninaction.com.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
Do it.
Thank you.
NICK BUTCHER: Awesome.
Sweet.
We good?